welcome to this video playing I am
Francesco 1i francesco de area ok Hugh
meter old wood old friends here yeah
this is some player that engine for ages
basically since I'm playing chess is
some that's not really really playable
Francesco queen edge for I think isn't
this Queen edge for good yeah I knowing
that since my childhood it's a couple of
years younger than me but we have played
in nine junior competitions and stuff
like that okay well Bishop d2 is I think
a mistake it gives away upon it's
difficult now for black to keep to keep
a pawn
if I was just detected I don't really
know how to how he should should cover
it takes before I take a knee forward
check okay took you didn't I went here
okay yeah there I'm a bit salad but a
bit confused why is this even playable
okay well I need to take anyway and now
if c7 hangs there's this word line the
Steinitz variation where black is even
playing king d 8 Adam it's I'm really a
bit mystified at the moment maybe they
do I wagon or is it Queenie sadness this
maybe though this now feels very tricky
what about the c7 porn I came yeah feat
if i take Knight takes Queen if five
Queen avoids just attacking it again
it simply does not look very good what
did I do wrong here I must have screwed
up the move order him really okay now
that's ugly really ugly but don't want
to play King da to really not okay and
now White has an excellent and excellent
compensation for the pawn it probably
will get it back somehow just normal
development now is good I really need to
check the specialty to is not playable
really what did I do wrong maybe Queenie
seven but a third difference still might
be five okay i will need to check this i
need to check this after the game okay
where to go if I for well yeah it's not
not nice
ok t5 a ship's III but I am I very ugly
Wow yeah 96 I might have night 95 let
you
you are just 25 m very ugly I need to
n85 badly by what I must move this
bishop okay maybe maybe I can somehow
yeah that really okay I can do that jump
96 maybe there's no immediate threat
maybe not maybe I get night at four in
here getting a hopeful again out of this
crappy position maybe night a foyer Oh
interesting
yum i cannot with the Queen ready by
five I can go to e7 takes on f5 takes on
you two but yeah but what what else I
don't see another movie Liam taking on
e5 wasn't great as well yeah even the
simple Queen trade is terrible for me
may there are many things that white can
play just 27 is just as good maybe
there's some better move I mean it
really looks like it looks terrible I
would just treat green Sam now I'm
threatening Queen g2 now
meow chattering mad check at least it's
a great night on f5 but still I have a
pawn on d7 and on b7 now but the night
on have five is brilliant so it's not
easy to dislodge you can go 94 of course
maybe maybe that's the way to go or
still night here to defy if something
like that yeah yeah this is what you can
try 97 coming or should I try something
like b5 here oh come on there should be
six it really feels like I'm risen from
the dead here she was a really terrible
just helium rook g1 I have g6
time warning just get get this exchange
dificil
again maybe take play a five and then
look G 1 this is a way to play Oh ruku
assumption Wow them protected
technically not not alert him we
generally not okay it's not going to
make me I believe
cancer it's just just a check detective
video ok autograph Jeff yeah adds four
seconds on the clock wyd worth it I'm
telling ya that was a very lucky winner
I mean and I first need to check I mean
this is really not playable Richard T to
a queen e seven now what is the point
because now i have d phi of young this
is the point three seven is just much
better because i have this protected i
played queen age fri and this is not not
good at all amazing yeah this is very
similar to the to the Sistine its
variation what I'm referring to is some
is this Queen age for here after which
white amongst others can play this move
check and here this is comparable to the
game and here black plays King the aid
to to cover c7 and then the in the game
jack she was it was quite comparable I
mean this is just so ugly but I didn't
want to play king the aid check maybe
this is still better this position he
has just the catastrophe and he think he
played it all right i mean the widest
always better him yeah therefore was
strong and i think he he should just
take on his seven him I mean Queen f5 is
probably a computer also gives queena
five as a win it's probably both winning
but of course he blundered Queen g2e
blundered 22 images here and I'm
completely paralyzed how am I ever going
to move that computer wants to play the
correct move Queen a six and then be
higher yeah this is just this is just a
terrible terrible sight yeah I was very
lucky that she running to run ran into
that and here this is probably a good
compensation for white but after you're
overlooking move like Ouija to achieve
terrible to keep your composure I think
here I think here he could check I could
could think about f5 damaging my pawn
structure even more and then play from
here I why do I can never lose this
really I mean Jesus is so maybe also
possible but okay he was destined to
lose some time oh I got the doorbell
ringing just a second I'm back back from
the tour got something delivered all
right um yeah I just was about to wrap
this rip up this game anyway I just a
very a very lucky win need to be lucky
sometimes and I just I must remember to
play Queenie seven-year next time
alright thanks for watching